what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and no I am not over
exaggerating in the title it looks like
a Marvel vs DC crossover is entirely
possible and actually has a chance of
happening it could even be in
development at Marvel Studios right now
of course very very early development in
the stages of just being talked about
which we actually do have a confirmation
of which of course we'll talk about in
this video but this is kind of the dream
Marvel and DC crossing over Iron Man
versus Batman Thor vs Superman Thanos
versus Darkseid and we can go on and on
Wonder Woman She-Hulk Black Widow
Aquaman all of these awesome characters
could be on the same screen together now
of course they've done this in Marvel
Comics we've had Marvel and DC
crossovers we never really thought it
would happen on film though however not
too long ago and over the past couple of
years we've heard rumors that they kind
of are talking about it over at DC and
Marvel and today we have confirmation
that that was indeed true and as it
turns out things are kind of lining up
perfectly for it to happen because James
Gunn was just announced to be the new
sort of Kevin feige over at DC Studios
he is co-ceo now and obviously James
Gunn has huge connections with Marvel
Studios and Kevin feige they love each
other of course James Gunn has directed
all of the guardians of the galaxies
including the holiday special and the
upcoming Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3.
he has done an amazing job with that
franchise but he has also done amazing
work over at DC directing and writing
quite possibly the best things to come
from DC like The Suicide Squad and
Peacemaker by far is one of the best
series and just projects in general to
come from DC period that show was
amazing and that's James Gunn and so
today an old interview that James Gunn
did with Jake's takes for the The
Suicide Squad is re-emerging because in
this interview he confirmed that there
have been talks about doing that
crossover and now James Gunn is co-ceo
of DC Studios which means the Marvel DC
crossover has a very real chance of
actually being made listen to what James
Gunn said in this interview with Jake's
takes about his thoughts about a Marvel
DC crossover film be happy to do a
Harley Quinn and Groot movie that would
be exciting for me and not only have I
thought about that but I've actually
talked about that to the heads of both
Marvel and DC but you know it's like
they you know everybody's open to
everything but whether anything would
ever happen who knows but the idea of
being able to bring uh Marvel and DC
together in a movie is that would be
really fun for me and I know it's
exciting for even the heads of Marvel
and DC to think about Kevin feige over
Marvel and Toby Emerick over at Warner
Brothers like they're you know it's
something we all like to dream about
whether we could ever get through the
barrage the Berlin Wall of lawyers we
would need to get through to ever make
something like that happen I don't know
but it would be a blast
so as you just heard this is something
that James Gunn actually wants to do and
has brought up to both heads of Marvel
Studios and the head over at Warner
Brothers but the only difference now is
there is a complete change in leadership
over at Warner Brothers in fact it is
now Warner Brothers Discovery and they
have now created a separate entity
titled DC Studios that's the name of
this new company and James Gunn has
recently been named co-ceo of DC Studios
and rightfully so like I mentioned
before he has done amazing work for DC
not only that but he has worked
extremely close with Kevin feige over at
Marvel Studios making amazing films and
directing the amazing Guardians of the
Galaxy franchise so this is quite
literally perfect for not only us fans
because now this has the chance to
actually happen but for James Gunn James
Gunn said both people in charge of
Marvel and DC slash Warner Brothers were
open to it but now he is one of the only
people who could actually make the call
to make this happen and he has publicly
stated that he wants it to happen and
has even brought it up before in the
past and the fact that him and Kevin
feige have worked together for many many
years is fantastic because this means
that they love working together I'm sure
they learn from each other and since
they get along well and typically share
some of the same Visions getting over
all of that legal stuff won't be exactly
too hard because it's easier when you're
with somebody you like and Kevin feige
has stated many times in the past before
and so was James Gunn that the studios
get along they root for each other they
are not against each other by any means
and it's not like Marvel wants the
Justice League to fail because they have
the Avengers or vice versa in fact it's
been stated many times that Kevin feige
has called the people over at DC and has
congratulated them on some of their
successful films so this is now
incredible news because the possibility
of having that Marvel DC crossover is
incredibly real and although this is
extremely new James Gunn just became
co-ceo over the past couple of days the
fact that he's brought this up before
means that he most likely will bring it
up again and bring it up to his old
buddy Kevin feige over at Marvel Studios
so while I don't think that it's going
to happen anytime soon I do think it is
a possibility for the future especially
with Secret Wars coming up and keep in
mind we are in the Multiverse Saga I
even stated way back before Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
came out where I thought it was going to
travel into just so many more universes
than we actually got that it was
possible for them to go into a DC
Universe and we could have even seen
Batman or Wonder Woman obviously that
didn't happen and the movie was on a
much smaller scale than a lot of us
thought it was going to be but it's
possible now which is super exciting to
think about I'm not saying Batman's
going to show up in secret Wars that's
not going to happen but a crossover film
could definitely be in our future and
I'm really really excited for that and I
hope it happens sometime within the next
few years heck I'd be excited if it came
out before I died but let me know how
excited you would be for this in the
comments down below let me know all your
thoughts please don't forget to like the
video and subscribe to stay up to date
on all Marvel related news for live
updates you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter and and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf